these people have been here since 4
o'clock in the morning waiting for you
to go and say hello to everyone but they
won't allow us to go over there there
would be a riot and also you don't have
your trampoline to do a double flip on
them exactly exactly thank you so much
for coming guys thank you dude this is
amazing grazie
look at this Hollywood Boulevard shut
down a giant spider man behind you it's
amazing it's crazy that this is all you
know our fifth plot my first time
playing spider-man the second time we
make one of these movies I mean it's a
dream come true in the job that keeps on
giving so much now you've actually been
the actual regular friendly Spider Man
all over the world because you helped
the person that fainted you went to the
Children's Hospital you've been helping
out like you're actually this is real
yeah I do my part where I can for sure
are you the real life spider-man no
everybody's a Spider Man you know it's
part of man belongs to everyone I think
the spider verse movie did so good at
like promoting this idea that anyone can
be spider-man
and you know if you can help out what
you can you should and that's what
Marvel and Sony help us do I love that
and Jake said you know when you guys
were in London you have very little time
off you took the time off to go to the
Children's Hospital in costume that's so
special right because it's just those
kids like you're changing their lives
yeah it's an amazing thing to be able to
do you know I mean these these kids it's
so nice we got to put a smile on their
face and and their parents and stuff and
if we can do that then we should we're
given such an amazing opportunity making
these movies and we're so lucky to be
doing it we'd be doing something wrong
if we weren't giving back to our
community so much okay question for you
who is your favorite bromance Avengers
bromance because you have good romances
with so many of the Avengers so there's
Hemsworth Robert Downey jr. and now Jake
Gyllenhaal if you had to pick a favorite
Avengers bromance for yourself Tom well
me and Downey isn't really a bromance
it's like a father/son mance which is a
little creepy but what's no creepy we're
just yeah I still have to be Jake it
have to be Jake you know he's right
beside you right now he is where's Jake
Gyllenhaal you know Jake and I wearing
the same shoes tonight and I'm wearing
them way better than him
don't tell him that um last thing what
do you think of the fame that your
brother who has come along he's been
filming you and making these movies what
do you think of him his Hollywood star
rising just by being along for the ride
well you know him and I we wanted to
write movies together we're writing a
film we're gonna hopefully direct it
this year and and him being a little bit
famous might help so yeah yeah
absolutely
thanks so much